Last class,
we talked about the brain.
Now want to talk a little bit about some foundations.
So today and Monday we're going to talk about two very big ideas.
And these ideas are associated with Sigmund Freud and BF,
Skinner and our psychoanalysis and behaviorism.
And I want to talk about psycho analysis today and behaviorism next week.
Now,
one of these things,
one of the things that makes these theories so interesting is there scope,
um,
most of the work we're going to talk about in this class,
most of the ideas are narrow.
So we're gonna talk about somebody somebodies idea about racial prejudice.
Um,
but that's not a theory of language acquisition.
We'll talk about theories of schizophrenia,
but they're not,
um,
explanations of sexual attractiveness.
Most theories are specialized theories,
but these two views or grand theories,
they're theories of everything encompassing just about everything that matters
day to day life,
child development,
mental illness,
religion,
war,
love,
Freud and Skinner had explanations of all of these.
Now this is not a history course.
I have zero interest in describing historical figures in psychology just for the
sake of telling you about the history of the field.
What I want to tell you about though is I want to talk about these ideas because
so much rests on them.
And even more importantly,
um,
a lot of these ideas have critical influence on how we think about the present
and that's there.
Now,
for better or worse,
we live in a world profoundly affected by Sigmund Freud.
If I had to ask you,
choose a psycho,
you know,
name a famous psychologist,
the answer most of you be Freud.
Um,
he's the most famous psychologist ever and he's had a profound influence on the
20th and 21st century.
Um,
some biographical information.
He was born in 1850s.
He spent most of his life in Vienna,
Austria,
and um,
but he died in London and he escaped to London soon after treating there,
um,
at the beginning of World War II as the Nazis began to occupy where he lived.
He's one of the most famous scholars ever,
but he's not known for any single discovery.
Instead,
he's known for the development of an encompassing theory of mind.
Um,
when did he developed over the span of many decades.
he was in his time,
extremely well known,
a celebrity recognize on the street and throughout his life he was a man of
extraordinary energy and productivity.
Um,
in part because he was a very serious cocaine addict,
but also just in general,
he was just a high energy sort of person.
He was up for the Nobel Prize in medicine and in literature.
Didn't get either one of them didn't get the prize in medicine because Albert
Einstein,
everybody loves Albert Einstein.
Well,
Albert Einstein really wrote a,
wrote a letter because they asked for opinions of other Nobel Prize,
wrote a letter saying don't give the price to Freud.
He doesn't deserve a Nobel prize.
He's just a psychologist.
Oh yeah.
S okay.
Um,
while he's almost universally acclaimed as a profoundly important intellectual
figure,
he's also the object of considerable dislike.
Um,
this is in part because of his character.
He was not a very nice man in many ways.
He was deeply ambitious to the cause of promoting psychoanalysis to the cause of
presenting his view and defending it.
Um,
and he was,
um,
often dishonest,
extremely brutal to his friends and,
and you know,
terrible to his enemies.
He was an interesting character.
My favorite Freud story was as he was leaving Europe during the rise of the
Nazis as he was ready to go to,
to go to England from,
um,
I think either Germany or Austria.
Um,
he had to sign a letter from the Gestapo.
Gestapo agents,
uh,
intercepted him and demanded he signed a letter saying that at no point had he
been threatened or harassed by the Gestapo.
So he signs the letter and any rights underneath it.
The Gestapo is not harm me in any way.
In fact,
I highly recommend a gestapo to everybody.
It's,
it's,
he had,
um,
a certain aggression to him.
Um,
he was also,
he's also disliked,
often hated because of his views.
He was seen as a sexual renegade out to destroy the conception of,
of people as good and rational and pure beings.
Um,
and when the Nazis rose to power in the 1930s,
he was identified as a Jew who was devoted to destroying the most sacred notions
of Christianity.
And to many extent,
to some extent,
um,
many people see in this way and to some extent,
this accusation has some truth to it.
Um,
Freud made claims about people that many of us,
maybe most of us would rather not know well,
okay,
what did he say?
Well,
if you ask somebody who doesn't like Freud,
what he said,
they'll describe some of the stupider things he said.
And in fact,
Freud said a lot of things,
some of which,
um,
were not very rational.
For instance,
um,
he's well known for his account of Phallic symbols,
arguing certain architectural monuments are,
are,
uh,
sub consciously developed as a penile representations.
Um,
and related to this,
he developed in a Tortilla.
It's theory of penis envy and penis envy isn't,
isn't an account of a developmental state that every one of you who is female
has gone through according to Freud and ideas that you discovered at some point
in your development that you lack the penis.
Um,
this is not,
this is a catastrophe.
And so each of you inferred at that point that you had been castrated.
You had once had a penis,
but somebody had taken it from you.
Um,
you then turn to your father and love your father because your father has a
penis.
So he's the sort of penis substitute.
Um,
you reject your mother who's equally unworthy due to her,
her penis lack.
And that shapes your psychosexual development.
Now,
if that's the sort of thing you know about Freud,
you're not going to have a very high opinion of him or of his work.
But at the core of Freud's explanation,
the more interesting ideas is this as a set of claims of immense intellectual
importance.
And the two main ones are this.
The two main ones involved.
The existence of an unconscious unconscious motivation.
And the notion of unconscious dynamics are unconscious conflict,
which lead to mental illnesses,
dreams,
slips of the tongue.
And so on.
The first idea,
the idea of unconscious motivation,
um,
involves rejecting the claim that you know what you're doing.
So suppose you fall in love with somebody and you decide you want to marry them,
and then somebody was asked to ask you why.
And you'd say something like,
well,
I'm ready to get married this stage in my life.
I really love the person to person is smart and attractive.
I want to have kids,
whatever.
And maybe this is true,
but a Freudian might say that even if this is your honest answer,
you're not lying to anybody else still.
Um,
there are desires and motivations that govern your behavior that you may not be
aware of.
Um,
so in fact,
you might want to marry John,
um,
because you remind you of your father or because you want to get back at
somebody for betraying you.
Um,
if somebody was to tell you this,
you'd say,
that's total nonsense,
but that wouldn't deter fraud.
And a Floridian would say that these processes are unconscious.
So of course you just don't know what's happening.
So the radical idea here is you might not know what,
why you do what you do.
And this is something we,
except for things like visual perception,
we accept that.
You look around the world and you get sensations and you figure it out.
There's a,
there's a card,
there's a tree there,
a person,
and you're just unconscious of how this happens,
but it's unpleasant and kind of frightening did this could happen.
This could apply to things like why you're now studying at Yale,
why you feel the way you do towards your friends,
towards your family.
Now,
the marriage cases extreme,
but Freud gives a lot of simpler examples where this sort of unconscious
motivation might play a role.
So have you ever liked somebody or dislike them and not not know why?
Have you ever found yourself in a situation where you're,
you're doing something or you're arguing for something or making a decision for
reasons that you can't fully articulate?
Have you ever forgotten somebody's name at exactly the wrong time?
Have you ever call it the wrong name in the throes of passion?
This is all the Freudian unconscious.
The idea is that we do these things.
These things are explained in terms of of cognitive systems that we're not aware
of.
Now,
all of this would be fine if you're unconscious was a reasonable rational
computer if you're unconscious was really smart and looking out for your best
interests.
But according to Freud,
that's not the way it works.
According to Freud,
there are three distinct processes going on in your head and these are in
violent internal conflict and the way you act in a way you think.
Our products not have a sealer,
rational being,
but have a set of conflicting creatures.
And these three parts are the Ed,
the ego,
and the Super Ego,
and they emerged developmentally.
The ID according to Freud,
is present at birth.
It's the animal part of the self.
It wants to eat,
drink,
pee,
poop,
get warm and have sexual satisfaction.
It is outrageously stupid.
It works on what Freud called the pleasure principle,
even wants pleasure and it wants it now.
And that's according to Freud,
how human begins pure Id.
Freud had this wonderful phrase,
polymorphous perversity is pure desire for pleasure.
Now unfortunately,
life doesn't work like that.
What you want isn't always what you get.
And this leads to a set of reactions to cope with.
The fact that pleasure isn't always there when you want it either by planning
how to satisfy your desires or planning how to suppress them,
and this system is known as the ego or the self and it works on the reality
principle and it it,
it works on the principle of trying to figure out how to make your way through
the world had a satisfy your pleasures or in some cases how to give up on them
and the ego,
the emergence of the ego for Freud symbolizes the origin of consciousness.
Finally,
if this was all there was,
it might be a simpler world,
but Freud had a third component that of the Super Ego and the Super Ego is the
internalized rules of parents and society.
So what happens in the course of development is you're just trying to make your
way through the world and satisfy your desires,
but sometimes you're punished for them some desires or inappropriate,
some actions are wrong and you're punished for it.
The idea is that you come out,
you get in your head a super ego,
a conscience in these movies.
It'd be like the little angel above your head that tells you when things are
wrong and basically yourself.
The Ego is in between the ID and the superego.
One thing to realize,
I told you the it is outrageously stupid.
It just says,
Oh,
hungry food,
sex,
oh,
let's get warm.
Oh,
the Super Ego is also stupid.
The Super Ego according to Freud is not some brilliant moral philosopher telling
you about right and wrong.
The Super Egos like you,
you should be ashamed of yourself.
That's disgusting.
Stop doing that.
Oh,
and in between these two screaming creatures,
one of you,
one of them telling you to seek out your desires to other one telling you should
be ashamed of yourself is you,
is the ego.
Now,
according to Freud,
most of this is unconscious.
So we see bubbling up to the top.
We feel we experience ourselves and the driving of the air,
the forces of the Ed and the forces of the Super Ego,
our unconscious in that we cannot access them.
We don't know what it's like,
the workings of our,
of our kidneys or our stomachs.
You can't introspect and find them.
Rather they do their work without conscious knowledge.
Now Freud develop this,
this is the Freudian theory.
In,
in,
in broad outline,
he extended it and developed it into a theory of psychosexual development.
And so Freud's theory is,
as I said before,
a theory of everyday life of decisions of errors are falling in love,
but it's also a theory of child development.
So Freud believed there were five stages of personality development and each is
associated with a particular erogenous zone.
And Freud believed as well that if you have a problem at a certain stage,
if something goes wrong,
you'll be stuck there.
So according to Freud or people in this room who are what they are because they
got stuck in the oral stage or an anal stage,
and,
and that's not good.
So the oral stage is when you start off the mouth is associated with pleasure,
everything is sucking and chewing and so on.
Um,
and the problem for Freud is premature weaning of a child depriving him of the
breast,
um,
could lead to serious problems in his personality development.
It could make him as the phrase go,
goes into an oral person and there's orality could be described.
Literally it,
Freud uses,
has an explanation for why somebody might eat too much or chew gum or smoke.
They're trying to achieve satisfaction through their mouth of a sort.
They didn't get in.
It's very early stage of development,
but it can also be more abstract.
Um,
if your roommate is dependent and needy,
you could then go to your roommate and say,
you are an oral person.
The first year of your life did not go well.
A phrase even more popular is the anal stage.
And that happens after the oral stage and problems can emerge.
Um,
if Paula training has not handled correctly,
if you have problems where he knows years of life,
you could become an anal personality.
Um,
according to Freud.
And your roommate could say your problem is you're too Amy.
And according to Freud,
literally it meant you were unwilling to part with your own feces.
Um,
it's written down here.
I know it's true.
Um,
and,
and the way it manifests itself as,
you know,
from just how people talk is your compulsive,
you're clean,
you're stingy.
This is the anal personality.
Then it gets a little bit more complicated.
Um,
the next stage is the phallic stage.
Actually,
this isn't that much more complicated.
The focus of pleasure shifts to the genitals.
Um,
and,
um,
fixation can lead to excessive masculinity in females or males or if you're
female,
need for attention or domination.
Now at this point,
something really interesting happens call the Oedipus complex.
And this is based on the story,
the mythical story of a king who killed his father and married his mother.
And according to Freud,
this happens to all of us in this way.
Well,
all of us by all of us,
Freud,
men,
men.
Um,
so here's the idea.
You're three or four years old,
you're in the phallic stage.
So what are you interested in?
What you're interested in your penis.
Um,
and then you seek an external,
our object,
Freud sort of vague about this,
but you know,
you seek some sort of satisfaction.
But who's out there,
who'd be sweet and kind and loving and wonderful.
Well mom,
so to trial and four in first mom is nice.
Hello mom.
So far,
so far.
So it's over.
This is not crazy little boy falling in love with his mother
problem.
Dad's in the way.
No.
Now this is going to get progressively weird,
but I won't have to say as the father of two of two sons,
both the signs when to a phase where they explicitly said they wanted to marry
mommy and me.
If something bad happened to me,
that wouldn't be the worst thing in the world.
So,
so,
so there's this,
but now it gets,
it gets a little bit aggressive.
So,
so the idea is that child determines that he's going to kill his father.
Every three and four year old boy thinks this.
Um,
but then because children according to Freud don't have a good sense of the
boundary between their mind in the world,
which is a problem.
The problem is,
is they don't,
they think their father can tell that they're plotting to kill him
and they figured a father is now angry at them.
And then they ask themselves,
what's the worst thing that could do to me?
And the answer is castration.
So they come to the conclusion that their father is going to castrate them
because they're elicit love for their mom.
And then they say bad ones and then they don't think about sex for several
years.
And that's the latency stage,
the latency stages.
They've gone through this huge thing of mom and dad fell in love of mom wanted
to kill my father.
Dad was going to castrate me,
fell out of love of mom,
editor x business.
And it's x's repressed until you get to the genital stage.
And the genital stage is the stage.
We are all in the healthy adult stage.
Um,
now,
now that you're adults and you've gone through all the developmental stages were
where do you stand?
You're not out of the woods yet because unconscious mechanisms are still,
even if you haven't got fixated or anything,
um,
there's still this dynamic going on all the time with your edge,
your ego,
and your Super Ego.
Um,
and the idea is your super ego.
Remember your Super Ego is stupid.
So your Subaru isn't only telling you not to do bad things.
It's telling you not to think bad things.
So what's happening is you're,
your ed is sending up all of this weird six stuff,
all of these crazy sexual and violent desires.
Oh,
I'll kill him.
I'll,
I'll have sex with that owl.
I'll have extra helpings on my dessert.
And,
and your Subaru,
you're super easy.
No,
no,
no.
And this stuff is repressed.
It doesn't even make it to consciousness.
The problem is Freud at a very sorta hydraulic theory of what goes on.
And some of the stuff slips out and it shows up in dreams and it shows up in
slips of the tongue and an exceptional cases.
It shows up in certain clinical symptoms.
So what happens is Freud described a lot of normal life as in terms of different
ways we use to keep that horrible stuff from the ear making its way to
consciousness.
And he called these defense mechanisms.
You're defending yourself against the horrible parts of yourself.
And some of these make a little bit of sense.
I mean,
one way to describe this in a non technical non Floridian ways,
there are certain things about ourselves we rather not know there are certain
desires we'd rather not know and we have ways to hide them.
So for instance,
there's sublimation.
Sublimation is you might have a line of energy,
maybe sexual energy or aggressive energy,
but instead of turning it to a sexual or aggressive target,
what you do is you focus it in some other way.
So you could imagine a great artists like Picasso turning the sexual energy into
his artwork.
There is,
um,
there's this placement.
This placement is,
um,
you have certain shameful thoughts or desires and you refocus the more
appropriately.
A boy who was bullied by his father,
um,
may hate his father and want to hurt him.
But since this would,
this is very shameful and difficult,
the boy,
you might instead kick the dog and it's,
think he hates the dog because that's a more acceptable target.
MMM.
There's projection projection is I have certain turn in pulses I'm uncomfortable
with.
So rather than own them myself,
I project them to somebody else.
A classic example for Freud,
this homosexual desires.
Um,
the idea is that I feel this tremendous lust towards you,
for instance,
and any,
any of you,
only you,
you three.
Um,
and,
and I'm ashamed of this lust.
So,
right?
So what I say is,
Hey,
are you guys looking at me in a sexual manner?
Are you lusting after me?
How disgusting.
Cause what I do is I take my own desire and I projected to others.
And Freud suggested perhaps not implausibly,
that man who believe other men who are obsessed with the sexuality of other men
are themselves projecting away their own sexual desires.
There's rationalization,
um,
which is that when you do something or think something bad,
you rationalize it and you give it a more socially acceptable explanation.
A parent who enjoys smacking his child will typically not say,
I enjoy smacking my child.
Rather we'll say it's for the child's own good.
I being a good parent by doing it this.
And finally there is regression,
which is returning to an earlier stage of development.
And you actually see this in children in times of stress and trauma.
They'll become younger,
they will act younger,
they might cry,
they might suck her thumb seek or blanket or so on.
Now these are all mechanisms that for Freud or not the slightest bit
pathological,
they're a part of normal life.
Normally we do these things to keep an equilibrium among the different systems
of the unconscious,
but sometimes it doesn't work.
Sometimes things go awry.
And what happens is a phrase that's not currently used in psychology.
It was popular during Freud's time.
Um,
hysteria.
Hysteria includes phenomena like hysterical blindness and hysterical deafness,
which is when you cannot see and cannot here,
even though there's nothing physiologically wrong with you.
Um,
paralysis,
trembling,
panic attacks,
gaps of memory,
including Amnesia and so on.
And the idea is that these are actually symptoms.
These are symptoms of mechanisms going on to keep things unconscious.
It's a common enough idea and movies often and movies,
what happens is somebody goes to an analyst,
they have some horrible problem,
they can't remember something or they have some sort of black outs and so on.
And the analyst tells them something and at one point they get this insight
and they realize what,
what,
why they blinded themselves,
why they can't remember.
And for Freud,
this is what happens.
Freud originally attempted to get these memories out through hypnosis,
but then move to the mechanism of free association.
And according to Freud,
the ideas,
patients offer resistance
to this.
And um,
and then the idea of a psycho analyst is to um,
get over the resistance and help patients get insight.
The key notion of,
of,
of psychoanalysis is your problems are actually,
um,
reflect deeper phenomena.
You're hiding something from yourself.
And once you know what's going on for deeper phenomena,
your problems will go away.
Okay.
I'm going to give you an example of a therapy session.
Now,
this is not a Freudian analysis we'll discuss later on in the course.
What are Freudian analysis is,
but this is not a pure 49th or 40 analysis supports is lying on a couch,
does not see their therapist or therapist is very non directive.
But I'm going to present this as an example here because it illustrates so many
of the Freudian themes,
particularly themes about dreams,
the importance of dreams,
about repression and about hidden meaning.
So this is from a television episode and the characters,
many,
some of you may have seen this,
many of you will not have the character is suffering from panic attacks.
Um,
in particular he has panic attacks when he sees his first panic attack
originated when he walked to a swimming pool and he saw a family of ducks fly
away and he had a panic attack,
heart high,
heart pounding,
sweating,
flushed and he passed out.
And these panic attacks grew worse and worse until he saw a therapist who ended
up prescribing a medication.
And this is discussed as one of,
is one of the meetings he had with the therapist.
Freud's contributions extend beyond,
um,
the study of individual psychology and individual pathology.
Um,
Freud had a lot to say about dreams.
Uh,
as you can see in this illustration,
he believed that dreams had,
um,
a manifest content meaning manifest meaning what you experienced in your dream.
But dreams always had a latent content as well,
meaning the hidden,
the hidden implication of the dream.
He viewed all dreams,
his wish fulfillment.
Every dream you have is a certain wish you have,
even though it might be a forbidden wish that you wouldn't wish to have,
you would want to have.
Um,
and dreams had.
And this is an idea,
a long predated Freud dreams had symbolism things in dreams.
We're often not what they seem to be,
but rather symbols for other things.
Um,
Freud believed that literature and fairy tales and stories to children and,
and the like,
um,
carried,
certain universal themes,
certain aspects of unconscious struggles in certain preoccupations of our
unconscious mind.
And Freud had a lot to say about religion.
Um,
for instance,
uh,
he viewed a large part of our,
um,
of the idea of finding a singular all powerful God as seeking out a father
figure that some of us never had during development.
What I want to spend the rest of the class on is the scientific assessment of
Freud.
So what I did was so far as I've told you what Freud had to say in broad
outline,
I then want to take the time to consider whether or not we should believe this
and how well it fits with our modern science.
But before doing so,
um,
I will take questions for a few minutes.
Do people have any questions about,
about Freud or Freud's theories?
Yes,
it's an excellent question.
The question is that the conflicts and psychosexual development that Freud
described is,
is always assumes that a child has a mother and a father,
one of each in a certain sort of familial structure.
And the question then is,
what if a child was raised by a single parent?
For example,
what if a child was never breastfed but fed from the bottle from the start?
And,
um,
and Freudians have had problems with this.
Freud.
Freud was very
okay,
focused on family life of the people he interacted with,
which is rather upperclass Europeans and,
and these sorts of questions would have been difficult for Freud to answer.
I imagine that would afford,
Ian would have to say as you would expect systematic differences.
So you would expect a child who just grew up with a mother just grew up to be a
father with a father to be in some sense psychologically damaged by that failing
to go through the normal psychosexual stages.
Yes.
Um,
the issue of the question is do modern psychoanalysts still believed that women
do not have super egos?
Um,
Freud was,
was,
as you're pointing out,
Freud was notorious for pointing for suggesting that women were morally immature
relative to men.
I think Freud would say that women had super egos.
They're just not the sort of sturdy ones that men have.
Um,
I think psychoanalysts and psychoanalytic scholars right now,
it would be mixed.
Some would maintain it a really our deep sex differences.
Others would want to jettison that aspect of Freudian theory.
Yes.
Well,
what's sublimation is a lot of these,
it's a good question.
The question is to sort of wet is sublimation,
how does it relate to other defense mechanisms?
A lot of defense mechanisms.
Um,
okay.
Involve taking a desire and turning it.
Now what displacement does is it takes it from you to her like I'm angry at you
but maybe that's forbidden for some reasons I'll be angry at her.
Um,
what projection does is takes a desire for me and then puts it on somebody else
heading outwards.
And what sublimation does is it just gives up the details and keeps the energy.
So you stay up,
you know,
your roommates stays up all night working and you say to your roommate for
instance,
um,
that's just because you haven't had sex in a long time and you want to have sex
to do it all your energy to your math exam and then,
and then you say,
that's sublimation.
I learned that in intro psych
and your room may be very pleased.
Um,
one more,
one more question.
Yes.
The question is,
which is related to the issue extending the issue of the two parent versus one
fat here and family is to what extent are these notions validated across?
And that's such a good question.
I'm going to defer it.
I'm gonna talk about it in a few minutes cause that's actually,
that speaks to the issue of the scientific assessment of fried.
So I'm going to try to get to your question in a little bit.
Um,
fry Friday and theory is now at this point,
the time extremely controversial.
Um,
and there was a lot of well known criticisms and attacks on Freud.
This is just the actually an excellent book on the memory wars by Frederick
Cruise,
which,
um,
and Frederick Cruz is one of the strongest and most passionate critics of Freud.
And the problems with Freud,
um,
go like this.
There are two ways you could reject the theory.
There are two problems with a scientific theory.
Um,
one way you could reject the theory is that it could be wrong.
So,
suppose I have a theory that the reason why some children have autism,
a profound developmental disorder is because their mothers don't love them
enough.
This is a popular theory for many years.
It's a possible theory.
It just turns out to be wrong.
But another way.
And so one way to attack and address a scientific theory is,
um,
is to view it as,
just to see whether or not it works.
But there's a different problem.
A theory could have a theory,
could be so vague and all encompassing that,
um,
that it can't even be tested.
And this is one of the main critiques of Freud.
Um,
the idea could be summed up by a quotation from the physicist Wolfgang Pauli and
Polly was asked his opinion about another physicist and Polly said this,
that guy's work is crap.
He's not right.
He's not even wrong.
And the criticism about Fridays is that he's not even wrong.
Um,
the issue of vagueness is summarize in a more technical way by the philosopher
Karl popper who describe who,
who introduced a term of falsifiability.
Uh,
the idea falsifiability
is that what distinguishes science from non science is that scientific
predictions make strong claims about the world.
And these claims are of a sort that they could be proven wrong if they couldn't
be proven wrong.
They're not interesting not to be science.
So for example,
Vince psychology,
the sorta claims will be entertaining throughout the course include claims like
damage to the hemp hippocampus causes failures of certain sorts of memory or
everywhere in the world,
man,
on average,
one to have more sexual partners than women or exposure to violent television
tends to make children themselves more violence.
Now,
are they true or are they false?
We'll,
we'll talk about that.
But the point here is they can be false there.
Interesting enough that they can be tested.
And as such,
they go to,
they might be wrong,
but they graduate to the level of a scientific theory.
Um,
this should be contrasted with nonscientific programs.
And the best example of a nonscientific program is astrology.
So the problem with a straw with astrological predictions is not that they're
wrong,
is that they can't be wrong.
They're not even wrong.
I did my,
I got my horoscope for today on the web.
Um,
a couple of negative aspects could make you a little finicky for next few days.
Okay,
I'm going to watch for that.
The presence of both Mars and Venus suggestion.
You want to box everything into a neat ordered stat structured way,
but keeping a piece of jade or chameleon close will help you keep in touch with
your fund side.
And starting this morning I got from my wife a little piece of jade and I had
been sort of in touch with my fun side.
The problem is a few days aren't going to go by and said,
God,
that was wrong.
It can't be wrong.
It's,
it's just so vague.
I got a better horoscope from the onion actually
riding in a golf cart with snow cone in hand.
You'll be tackled by two police officers this region after imagining your
competence,
that caricature of I've suspected murderer.
Now
that's,
that's a good prediction because,
because wow,
if it's,
if it turns out to be true,
I'm going to say those guys really know something.
It's falsifiable.
Um,
arguably Freud fails the test because Freudian theory is often so vague and
flexible that it can't really be tested in any reliable way.
A big problem of this is a lot of Freudian theory is claimed to be validated in
the course of psycho analysis.
So when you ask people,
why do you believe in fried,
they won't say,
oh,
because of this experiment,
that experiment,
this Dataset and that Dataset.
What I'll say is it's Freud's,
the Freudian theory proves itself in the course of psycho analysis,
the success of psychoanalysis.
But it's unreliable.
I mean the problem and say,
Freud says to a patient,
you hate,
your mother.
Patient says,
wow,
that makes sense for it says,
I'm re phrase it,
you hate your mother.
I mean there's no,
I don't want to stare like that's disgusting.
Freud says your anger shows this idea is painful for you.
Who Preston from dying.
I am right.
And,
and the problem is the
same sort of dynamic plays itself out even in the scientific debate back and
forth.
Um,
so Freud,
Freud and psychologist,
I'm putting Floyd here,
but what I mean is well known defenders are for,
we'll make some claims like,
you know,
adult personality traits are shaped by the course of psychosexual development.
All dreams or disguise,
wish fulfillment.
Psychoanalysis is the best treatment for mental disorders.
Scientists will respond.
I disagree.
There's little to no evidence supporting those claims and fraud in responses.
Your rejection of idea shows that he or distressing to you.
This is because I am right.
And this is often followed up seriously enough.
You have deep psychological
problems
and
now,
no,
I don't want to caricature her.
Freudians a lot of Floridians have tried and made a research program of
extending their ideas,
scientifically,
bringing them to a robust scientific tests.
MMM.
But the problem is when you make specific falsifiable predictions,
they don't always do that well.
Um,
so for instance,
there's no evidence that oral and anal characteristics,
the personality characteristics I talked about,
about being needy versus being stingy,
relate in any interesting way to weaning or toilet training.
And there's been some efforts cross culturally to it.
To go back to the question this young man asked before looking at cross cultural
differences in toilet training and weaning,
which are really big differences to see if they correspond in any interesting
way to personality differences.
And there's been no good evidence supporting that.
Um,
similarly,
um,
Freud had some strong claims about sexuality for why some people are straight
and others are gay.
Um,
these have met with very little empirical support
and the claim that psycho analysis proves itself by being by its tremendous
success in curing mental illness is also almost certainly not true for most,
maybe not all,
but for most psychological disorders there are quicker and more reliable
treatments,
then psycho analysis.
And there's considerable controversy as to whether the Tony Soprano method of
insight where you get an insight and there's discovery,
oh,
now I know makes any real difference in alleviating symptoms such as anxiety
disorders or depression.
Um,
this is why,
who sort of often sort of a sticker shock when people go to a university
psychology department where they say,
look,
hey,
where's,
um,
so I mean,
it's like how can I take classes on Freud?
Who's your expert on Freud?
And the truth is Freudian psychoanalysis is almost never studied inside
psychology departments.
Um,
not the cognitive or developmental side,
not the clinical side.
There are some exceptions,
but for the most part,
even the people who do study for right within psychology departments do so
critically.
Not Very few of them would see themselves as a psycho analytic practitioner or
as a Freudian psychologist.
Um,
Freud lives on both in a clinical setting and in the university.
But Freud at Yale for instance,
as much more likely to be found in the history department or the literature
department been in the psychology department.
And is this typical enough?
But
despite all of this sort of sour things I just said about Freud,
the big idea,
the importance of the dynamic unconscious remains intact.
We will go over and over and over again.
Different case studies were some really interesting aspects of mental life.
Prove to be unconscious.
Now there's one question.
I'm actually going to skip over this for reasons of time.
Um,
and just go to some examples of the unconscious in modern psychology.
So here's a simple example of the unconscious in modern psychology.
Um,
language understanding.
So when you hear a sentence like
John thinks that bill likes him in a fraction of a second,
you realize that this means that John thinks the bill likes John.
If you were to sentence oops,
John thinks that bill likes himself in a fraction of a second,
you would think that it means John thinks that bill likes bill.
And as we will get to when we get to the lecture on language,
this is not conscious.
You don't know how you do this.
You don't even know that you are doing this,
but you do it quickly and instinctively.
So much of our day to day life can be done unconsciously.
Um,
there are different activities you can do driving,
chewing gum,
shoe lace,
tying where if you're good enough at them,
if you're expert enough at them,
you don't know you're doing them.
I was at a party a few years ago for a friend of mine and we ran out of food.
So he said,
oh,
I'll just go pick up some food.
An hour later he was gone.
Still gone and it was supposed to be around the corner and we call them up on
his cell phone and he said,
oh,
I got on the highway and I drove to work.
He works like an hour away.
We go on the highway and the some version of these things happen all the time.
Yeah.
Maybe more surprising Freud's insight that our likes and dislikes are due to
factors that were not necessarily conscious of,
has a lot of empirical support,
a lot of empirical support from research into social psychology,
for example.
Um,
so here's,
here's one finding from social psychology.
Um,
if somebody goes through a terrible initiation to get into a club though,
like the club more,
you might think they'd like it less because people do terrible things.
But actually hazing is illegal,
but a remarkably successful tool.
Um,
the more you pay for something,
the more you like it and the more pain you go through to get something,
the more you'd like it.
Um,
from the standpoint of political of politics,
for instance,
um,
if you,
if you want loyal people in a political campaign,
do not pay them.
If you pay them,
they'll like you less.
If they volunteer,
they'll like you more.
And we'll talk about why there's different theories about why.
But my point right now is simply that people don't necessarily know this,
but still they're subject to this.
Another example is some weird studies done in a discipline of social psychology
known as terror management,
um,
which involves subliminal death primes.
The idea of subliminal death primes is this,
you sign up for your human subjects requirement and then you,
um,
they put you in front of a computer screen and then they tell you,
oh,
just sit in front of a computer screen and we'll ask you some questions.
And then the questions come out and her questions like,
how much do you love your country?
What do you think of Asians?
What do think of Jews?
What do you think of blacks?
I think of vegetarian,
we think people political views different from yours.
Here's the gimmick.
What you don't know is on that computer screen,
words are being flashed
like that,
but there are being flashed so fast it looks like,
like that you don't see anything where it's like corpse dead,
dying.
The flashing of these subliminal word,
subliminal meaning a fancy term meaning below the level of consciousness you
don't know you're seeing them has dramatic effects on how you answer those
questions.
People exposed to death crimes,
um,
become more nationalistic,
more patriotic,
less forgiving of other people,
less liking of other races and people from other countries.
Again,
the claim back summation for why this is so is something which we'll get to
another class.
The point now is simply to illustrate that these sorts of things can have,
that things you aren't aware of can have an effect on how you,
I think the final example I'll give this is a short demonstration.
Um,
to do this,
I'm going to cut the class in half at this point.
So you'll be on this side of the class,
the right side,
my right,
and this will be on the left side.
And I simply want,
okay,
everybody to think about somebody you love.
So think about somebody you love,
your girlfriend,
your boyfriend,
your mom,
your dad.
Think about somebody you love.
Just,
okay.
Now
on this screen is going to be instructions,
but I want to give them instructions to this half of the class.
I'm going to ask everybody in this half the class,
please either turn your head or shut your eyes.
Okay?
Teaching fellows to buy and everybody on this half obey.
Has Everybody read that?
Okay?
Okay,
now turn your head this group.
Now this group,
look at this
can take a moment.
You don't have to do it on paper,
but take a moment to do it in your head.
You,
each group had instructions,
some people might have seen both instructions.
Follow the instructions that you bought for you.
Okay?
Now this was research done
by Norbert Schwarz.
And
here's the question I want you to ask yourself.
How much do you like this person?
Okay,
and here's the effect.
Half of you were asked to list three features of the person.
Half of you were asked to list 10.
The finding,
which is not a subtle finding is that liking goes up in the three group and
liking goes down in the 10 group.
And here's why.
I have to think about um,
three positive features of um,
of somebody.
So I don't think my girlfriend,
I have a girlfriend,
I think my daughter,
oh,
she's smart,
she's beautiful and she's kind of good.
How much do,
what do,
what do I think of her?
Pretty good.
SMART,
beautiful con might be well,
yeah,
but the problem now,
Schwartz is clever though.
He says,
listen,
the other group gets 10 positive features.
SMART,
beautiful,
kind,
really nice,
good cook,
punctual,
smart.
No,
I mentioned that.
The problem is nobody has 10 positive features
and,
and
that they're being asked to do 10 pounds and features is people find this hard
and then those people won't ask,
how much do you like this person?
I'm say,
couldn't really make it that 10.
I guess.
I don't like them very much.
Not appointed.
This illustration again is that it shows that you don't know this subjects who,
who are asked to do 10 positive features and then later ranked a person lower
and then ask why did you rank the person lower?
Don't say because you told me to list him.
Typically we are oblivious to these factors that change our points,
what we like and what we dislike.
And this is in fact a substantial and important part of the study of psychology
and particularly for instance the study of racial and sexual prejudice.
We're one of the big findings from social psychology and we'll devote almost an
entire lecture to this,
is that people have strong views about other races,
um,
that they don't know about
and that they don't know,
control their actions.
So to some extent this rounds out Freud cause it's to some extent,
um,
the particulars of Freud are for the most part have been rejected.
But the general idea of Freud is actually,
it's been so successful both in the study of scientific psychology and in our
interpretation of everyday life that to some extent Freud's been a victim of his
own success.
We tend to to underestimate the importance of Floridian thought in everyday
life.
Um,
because he's transformed our worldview to session extent that it's difficult for
us to remember that there's any other way to think about it.
So to some extent he's been a victim of his own success.
We have time for,
um,
for some further questions about Freud and about scientific implications of
fried.
Yeah.
I took a class once on how to teach when I was a graduate student and I just
remember two things from this class.
One thing is never great and red pen posted.
People don't like that.
The second thing is never ask any questions because [inaudible] is very
frightening to any questions and people find it's intimidating I suppose to ask.
What are your questions?
So what are your questions?
Yes.
And back.
Sorry.
Detroit believe in
medication.
Fred Headen it's a good question.
Um,
the question was does the Freud believe in medication?
Medication of course being a major theme of how we deal with certain disorders
now,
particularly depression and anxiety disorders.
Um,
on the one hand Freud made it start as a neuroscientist.
Freud studied the mind and the brain,
and it was intensely interested in the neural basis of thought and behavior.
But to answer your question to end is no,
although Freud was very sensitive to the brain basis of behavior,
Freud was totally convinced that the method through which to cure disorders like
depression and anxiety would not be medication.
Um,
but rather through the sort of talk therapy and insight.
Moreover,
modern psycho and modern therapists,
including some people who aren't psychoanalytically,
um,
define,
we'll say,
look,
these drugs are all well and good,
but what they do with they mask the symptoms.
So if you have panic attacks,
say it's true that drugs might make the panic attacks go away,
but the panic attacks are actually not your real problem.
And by making them go away,
you don't get to the root of your problem.
So dancers,
both Freud and modern day psychoanalysts would think that medications are
substantially overused in the treatment of mental disorders.
Yes.
Yeah.
The question is what about research on dreams?
Dreams is such a fun topic that I want to devote half a class to sleeping and
dreams.
So,
for instance,
I will answer the question,
what is the most common dream?
I will also answer the question,
who thinks about sex more and greens,
men or women?
And what proportion of,
oh,
there's so many great questions.
I won't answer dreams from a [inaudible] standpoint.
Um,
there's been some evidence that dreams do in some often do have some
relationship to what you're thinking about and worrying about through the day,
but the strong Freud Ian View.
But symbolism and wish fulfillment has not been supported by the study of
dreams.
Right.
What are your other questions?
Yes.
Whoever Eric is pointing to.
Purple Shirt.
Yes.
The electro complex.
The Electra Complex is the penis envy story.
Um,
Freud developed business.
This is it.
This is a crude summary,
but Freud developed the oedipal complex.
You know,
mom,
I love mom.
He dead.
And then it's as if somebody reminded him sigma.
Then there are also women.
Oh yeah.
And that story I told you with the penises and the penis envy and a replacement
is a sort of a very shortened version of electra complex.
I think it's fair to say that Electra Complex was,
I sort of add on to the main interest of fraud,
the oedipal complex.
Okay.
Uh,
one more please.
Yes,
sorry,
go ahead.
Uh,
according to Freud,
um,
the,
it's not a fixation in the stage in the same sense as an oral or anal stage,
but yes,
the claim that Freud would make is that the woman's discovery that she lacks the
penis plays a fundamental role later on determining her allegiances and like,
and in fact,
her own sexual preferences and interests.
So it was not the sort of thing that affects her just for a short period.